let's explore probability density
functions a little bit further and here
I have drawn one for the random variable
let's call this random variable G just
for a little bit of variety here so G is
a continuous random variable and here is
this probability density function and I
like this one because this is non
uniform now the first question I have
for you assuming that it continues to be
a zero probability as we go a greater
than five and a zero probability as we
are less than one is what is this height
have to be in order for this to be a
legitimate probability density function
for G for this random variable well all
of the possible outcomes are between 1
and 5 including 1 and 5 and so the
combined probability of all of these
outcomes has to be equal to 1 and so
this area right underneath this curve
the area right underneath this curve
needs to be equal to 1 well that area is
going to be whatever this height is
whatever this height is let's call that
H whatever that height is times the base
times 1/2 is going to be equal to 1 so
what's that height going to be let's see
1/2 times the base so the base is 4 wide
goes between 1 and 5 so it's 4 wide so
1/2 times 4 times the height has to be
equal to 1 and I can only do this
because this is pretty straight forward
geometric figure if this is some type of
a curve I would have to break out a
little bit of the calculus but anyway
let's work with this one
so what 1/2 times 4 is 2 2 times H is
equal to 1 H divide both sides by 2 H is
going to be equal to 1/2 so so this
height right over here this height right
over here is going to be equal to 1/2
and now we've constructed a legitimate
probability distribution for our random
variable G now given this non continuous
probability density function here so
once again let me make clear this is the
p DF probability density function and we
could actually describe this
analytically if you want to figure out
the
Asians for these lines you could say
it's equal to it's equal to this line
the density function is equal to this
line between 1 & 3 it's equal to this
line between 3 & 4 3 & 5 it's zero above
five zero below one we could figure that
out and it's actually a fun thing to do
if you're if you're in the mood but
let's think about some probabilities
here what is the probability that our
random variable G is greater than or
equal to two and less than or equal to
three what's that probability going to
be well once again we're talking about
the range it can be two it could be
anywhere between two and three including
two and three so we're essentially
talking about the area under the curve
between two and three so we're talking
about we're talking about this area
right over here which is a trapezoid so
the one way I think about the area of a
trapezoid you can especially when it's
oriented this way it's the mean of the
two heights the two different heights
times the base so this the base here is
one the base here is one and then the
two the mean of the two heights so it's
going to be plus or cisely say times one
half times this height on the left hand
side and what's this going to be
we're uniformly over two spaces over two
spaces we are going up one half so over
one space we're just going to go up one
fourth so this right over here is going
to be one fourth so this height right
over here is going to be one fourth and
then in and then this height over here
we already figured it out this the
density at G and for G equals three is
at the density there is one half so one
fourth plus one half and so this part of
the expression gives us our mean density
over this range it's linear so it works
out well for us if this was a curve once
again we'd have to break out the
calculus we're really just taking the
area of this trapezoid this this base is
one this base is one and then we're
multiplying it times the mean
height of the trapezoid so this is going
to be this is going to be equal to a 1
times anything is anything it's going to
be 1/2 times 1/4 plus 1/2
well 1/4 well that's 1/4 plus 2/4 which
is 3/4 which is equal to 3 over 8 so the
probability the G for this non uniform
distribution that G is between 2 & 3 is
equal to 3/8 now let me ask you another
question and this is really to what we
saw in the last video but just a little
bit of practice what is the probability
that G is going to be equal to exactly
exactly 3 what is this probability well
here we're dealing with the area
remember this is a density function so
this is it tells you how dense the
probability is at that point but if
we're really talking about an infinitely
infinitely thin rectangle here which we
are we're talking about being precisely
3 not 2 0.9999 not 3.000 1 not anything
in between we have to or the only thing
in between that would satisfy it is when
we are exactly three and we see here
that when you have a height of 1/2 but
the base of your rectangle has you have
no width you have no base so you have an
a rectangle with no width has zero area
so once again this probability this
probability is going to be equal to zero
which I will which leads to another
interesting question here we saw that
the probability that G is between 2 & 3
including 2 & 3 was equal to 3/8 what is
going to be the probability what is
going to be the probability if I were to
say G is between 2 & 3 let me write it
this way G is between 2 & 3 but it won't
make it but we're not talking about the
situations when it is exactly equal to 2
or exactly equal to 3 but it could be
anything in between any number it could
be two point zero zero zero zero zero
one or two point nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine we're just not talking
about the scenario where it's exactly
three or the scenario where it's exactly
two what is this probability going to be
where these are strictly less than signs
less than or equal well it's still
actually going to be equal to 3/8 the
one way you could think about it this is
still going to be the area of this same
trapezoid we've subtracted out these
infinitely thin rectangles at each
boundary which each have zero area if
you take something if you take two zero
areas away from an area you still have
an area of 3/8 so a little
philosophically interesting a little
something for you to think about